- What's up believe nation?
I started the Mentor Me series
to try to learn from people
who've done a lot more than us,
spend a little bit more time
with them, and hopefully
some of their beliefs,
their viewpoints, their
mindset, seeps into us
to help us become the
best version of ourselves.
So today we're going to learn
from Arnold Schwarzenegger
and some of his most inspiring moments.
Mentor me, Arnold.
And as always guys, as
you're watching the videos,
if you see something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired.
And if you write it down,
it's much more likely
to stick with yourself as well.
(inspiring music)
- The most important thing
is that you have a vision.
That you have a goal.
Because without that vision
and without that goal,
again you're drifting
around and you're never
going to end up anywhere.
People don't become
successful just by accident.
I mean maybe the guy that
found gold in California
and started the gold rush,
but don't count on that.
That's one in a lifetime
kind of situation.
So you've got to really have
a specific goal, and to me,
to have that vision that
I want to be Mr. Universe,
that I want to be the greatest
body builder of all time,
that was a great vision
and specifically to look
like Reg Park and to be
up there on that stage
and to lift the trophy overhead
and to win the championship
over and over and over again.
So that was a great goal,
you have to have a goal.
Now it doesn't have to
be that specific goal,
but it has to have some goal.
This is why I always
recommend to people, sit down,
take your time, and start thinking about
why do you want to work out?
What is your goal?
And it can be as crazy
as it is, it could be
I want to impress girls.
If that's your goal, so be
it, but it motivates you.
It could be that you're
emulating a certain body builder
or a certain football
player or a certain boxer.
Whatever it is, have those
pictures put all over the wall
like I did when I was a kid,
I put pictures of Reg Park
and of Sonny Liston,
of boxers, and of Ali,
and of power lifters, and weight
lifters all over my bedroom
in a wall so that every
day when I go to sleep,
every day when I wake up,
I look at those pictures
and they motivate me.
You need that motivation and
therefore you have to kind of
imprint in front of you all the time
and you know exactly what you're chasing.
This is why I always smiled
when I was in the gym.
People always came up to me and says
why are you smiling, you're
working out five hours a day.
You're doing the same as the other guys,
but the other guys have a
sour face, they're pissed off
that they have to do another rep
or another set or something.
I looked forward to, I looked
forward to another thousand
reps of sit ups, I looked
forward to another 500 pounds
of leg press or squat.
I looked forward doing more and more curls
until my arms fall off.
Why, because I knew that
every rep that I did
and every set that I did and
more weights that I lifted,
I get one step closer to turning
that vision into reality.
So I was turned on by that, I was excited.
I couldn't wait to get to the gym.
When I used to do seminars
on how to become a champion
I would always ask people why
do you want to be a champion?
Or what do you want to accomplish?
Why are you training?
And if a guy will get up, and he will say,
well I want to train because
I think that if I get muscular
and I feel like I'm getting
the kind of definition
then I maybe can enter a
body building competition.
I said, sit down.
Cause if you think this way,
you're going to be a loser.
You're never going to make
it because there's no maybe.
You got to get up and say,
I want to be a champion.
And I do whatever it takes.
The amount of hours it takes, the posing,
the this, the that, the visualization.
Looking at training footage,
looking at motivational books,
reading this, whatever
it takes, I will do.
That's the answer I want to hear from you.
You can detect right away those
that are going to be shaky
and that will fall behind.
They will not go all the way.
And those that are very hungry.
And that hunger you have to
develop because you have to
create a goal for yourself,
whatever that may be.
A short-term goal and a
long-term goal and you got to go
after that and if you do not see it,
and if you do not believe
it, who else will?
Don't be afraid to fail.
Anything I've ever attempted,
I was always willing to fail.
In the movie business I
remember they depict scripts.
Many times you think
this is a winning script,
but then of course you find out later on
when you do the movie that it didn't work
and the movie goes in the toilet.
Now we have seen my
movies, I mean, Red Sonja,
Hercules in New York, Last Action Hero.
Those movies went in the toilet.
But that's okay, because at
the same time I made movies
like Terminator and Conan
and True Lies and Predator
and Twins that went through the roof.
So you can't always
win but don't be afraid
of making decisions.
You can't be paralyzed by fear or failure
or you will never push yourself.
You keep pushing because
you believe in yourself
and in your vision and you
know that it is the right thing
to do and success will come.
So don't be afraid to fail.
- In one word, one word only,
how did a small town boy
from Austria become one of the
most famous people on earth?
- Why do you want me
to say it in one word?
(laughter)
- One word, Arnold.
- I don't stay with your rules.
Dream.
- Dream.
I was poor because I didn't have anything.
I had no money, I had
no things, we had no TV,
we had no refrigerator,
we had nothing as kids.
But I was rich because I had a dream.
- You had a dream.
- I had a dream of becoming
the greatest body builder
and I had a dream to use body building
as a means to get into films.
But I had no idea that it
would go as far as it did.
That it would go beyond the
body roles, beyond the muscles
and into movies like Terminator,
Predator, End of Days,
and stuff like that.
That was like, you know, I had
to kind of reinvent my dream
after I achieved that.
- Okay, but this dream of body
building, we'll come to that,
but there must have been a
time in your life before that
when you didn't have thoughts
of body building at all.
What sort of child were you?
- Well I grew up in
Austria, I was born after
the second World War in
1947, it was poverty.
There was no food around, really nothing.
And I think that was the
reason why I developed
such a tremendous desire to
get out of there and a desire
to make it in life, to achieve big things.
And then when I learned in
school later on about America
and about the skyscrapers,
the big freeways, the big cars
and all that, I said Miss Avine, I want to
be part of this big thing.
Everyone has a problem with time.
But the day is 24 hours and we sleep six.
Now I know there are
some out there that say
Oh woah, woah, woah, woah, I need eight.
Well I say, just sleep a little faster
because the bottom line is
we have six hours of sleep,
24 hours are available so you
have 18 hours now available
to your work, your family,
your hobbies, and also
to learn something new
or to do something new.
Which could easily be that you
want to learn a new language,
or that you want to read
as a New Years resolution,
have to read a book every week or you say
I'm going to go and re-shape my body.
So you're going to go and take this hour
out of your schedule and
say I'm going to train
an hour every day.
So this is for most
people a huge challenge
but it is totally doable, I can tell them.
Because the kind of things that I did
when I came to this country.
I mean, I went to school, I
was working in construction,
I was working out five
hours a day, I was taking
acting classes from eight
o'clock at night to 12 midnight.
I was doing all of those things.
I wanted to make sure that
out of the 24 hours of the day
that I don't waste one single hour.
Those hours were too precious.
And so then I just want to tell people
don't give me this thing,
I have a difficult time
with the time, and I don't have
time for this, none of that.
You have time, you make the time.
When you're a competitive
athlete, you learn very quickly
how strong you are or
how energetic you are.
All of those things.
But, it could very well be
that there's a lot of people
who have an equally as
good a body as you have.
That performs just as
well, that is as muscular,
the same body building, that
has exactly the same kind of,
you know, proportions
and all of those things.
So the question really is is
what puts you over the top?
It is the mind that
really creates the body.
It's the mind that makes
you really work out
the four or five hours a day.
It is the mind that
visualizes of what the body
ought to look like as
the finished product.
The body is very important,
but the mind is more important
than the body.
You have to visualize what
that body ought to look like
in order to make it win.
Because that's what creates then the will.
The will that you need to
go to the gym every day.
The will that makes you
go into the four steps.
The will that makes you go
beyond and you do your 500 pound
reps and the squats and
you can't do another rep,
and your body is shaking,
it's the will that makes you
go one more time down and
struggle up one more time.
And since all of this is the mental aspect
that motivates you, and
that makes the difference
of you being in the gym full
of joy and looking forward
to doing that extra rep and
looking forward to doing
those extra hundred reps and the sit-ups
and working past the pain periods.
That's all is the mind,
that's not the body.
So this is why I think
the body is very important
but the mind is more
important than the body.
You have so many rules
in life about everything.
I say break the rules, not
the law, but break the rules.
My wife has a t-shirt, my
wife has a t-shirt that says
Well behaved women rarely make history.
Well you know, I don't
want to burst her bubble,
but the same is true with men.
It is impossible to be a
maverick or a true original
if you're too well-behaved and don't want
to break the rules.
You have to think outside the box.
That's what I believe.
After all, what is the
point of being on this earth
if all you want to do
is be liked by everyone
and avoid trouble.
The only way that I ever got any place
was by breaking some of the rules.
After all, I remember that
after I was finished with my
body building career, I
wanted to get into acting,
and I wanted to be a star in films.
You can imagine what the agents said
when I went to meet all those agents.
Every one had the same
line, that it can't be done.
The rules are different here.
Says look at your body, you
have this huge, monstrous body,
overly developed, that
doesn't fit into the movies.
You don't understand.
This was 20 years ago,
the Hercules movies.
Now there is the little guys
today and Dustin Hoffman,
Woody Allen, Jack Nicholson,
before he gained weight
of course, that is.
But anyway, those are the guys that win.
And the agent also
complained about my accent.
He says no one ever became a
star with an accent like that.
Especially not with a
German accent and yes,
I can imagine with your name,
Arnold Schwarzen-schnitzle,
or whatever the name is, on a billboard.
Yeah that's going to draw a
lot of tickets and sell a lot
of tickets, yeah right.
So this is the kind of
negative attitude they had,
but I didn't listen to those rules.
Even though they were very
nice and they said look,
we can get you some good parts.
We can get you to playing
a wrestler or bouncer.
Oh, maybe with your German
accent we can get you
to be a Nazi officer in Hogan's Heroes
or something like that.
But, you know, I didn't
listen to all those.
Those were their rules, not my rules.
I was convinced I could do
it, that if I worked as hard
as I did in body building,
five hours a day.
And I started getting to
work, I started taking
acting classes, took English
classes, took speech classes,
dialogue classes, accent
removal classes I even took.
I remember running around,
a fine wine grows on a vine.
Is it because Germans have
difficulties with the F and the W
and the V, so fine wine grows on a vine.
I know what some of you now
say is that hope that Arnold
got his money back, but
let me tell you something.
I had a good time doing those things
and they really helped me
and finally I broke through.
I broke through and I started
getting the first parts
in TV, Streets of San Francisco,
Lucille Ball hired me.
I made Pumping Iron, Stay Hungry.
And then I got the big break
in Conan the Barbarian.
And there the director say if
we didn't have Schwarzenegger
we would have to build one.
Now think about that.
And then, when I did
Terminator, I'll be back,
became one of the most famous
lines in movie history.
All because of my crazy accent.
Now think about it, the
things that the agents said
would be totally a detriment
and would be impossible
for me to get a job all of a
sudden became as asset for me.
All of those things, my accent,
my body, and everything.
So it just shows to you, never listen
that you can't do something.
And you have to work your way up,
of course, run for something else first.
I mean it was the same, and
I when I ran for governor,
the same lines, that you
have to work your way up,
it can't be done.
And then of course, I ran
for governor, and the rest,
of course, is history.
They said you have to start
with a small job as mayor.
And then there's assemblyman, and then
there is lieutenant governor,
and then as governor.
And they said that's the way
it works in a political career.
I said I'm not interested
in a political career.
I want to be a public servant.
I want to fix California's
problems and bring people
together and bring the parties together.
So like I said, I decided to
run, I didn't pay attention
to the rules and I made it
and the rest is history.
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I'd love to know, what did
you think of this video?
What did you learn from
Arnold that's going to have
the biggest immediate impact
on your life or your business?
Which one was your favorite clip and why?
Please leave it in the
comments below and I'm going to
join in the discussion.
Finally, I want to give a quick shout out
to Vincent Montello.
Vincent, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and making
that book summary video
on your YouTube channel,
I really, really, really
appreciate the support.
- Today, we are covering Evan
Carmichael's Your One Word.
- So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.